joining me now to react is Harmeet
Dillon attorney and Trump 2020 Advisory
Council member and Francisco Hernandez
immigration attorney
thank you both you and I are hearing
this these results in real-time I've got
the us-mexico joint declaration in front
of me and you heard it Mexican national
guard to their southern border migrants
who are seeking adjudication for asylum
sent back to Mexico Mexico agrees with
that and the whole thing reviewed 90
days from now to see whether or not
Mexico is actually fulfilling it so
Harmeet when you look at this and you
consider what America gave up which is a
tariff that never was imposed but was
threatened your reaction well tariffs
are not the favored tool of most
conservatives Pete however desperate
times call for desperate measures as we
can see here it worked and I think it is
a great result for America and actually
a pretty good result for Mexico as well
because Mexico is actually been getting
the benefit of allowing the current
situation there are a lot of remittances
some forty billion dollars going back to
Mexico every year and and it's not
working and so neighbors need to work
out their disputes and now in addition
to the terms that you mentioned it's
also going to include the National Guard
actually fanning out throughout Mexico
interdicting gangs and smuggling rings
and helping with that and also providing
some support and even potentially jobs
to those asylum seekers who are waiting
for their applications to be processed
in America so I think it's gonna be
actually great for those people who are
seeking to come to this country as well
they can be in a safe environment and be
supported there in Mexico while America
makes a rapid determination about
whether they're eligible or not yeah
Francisco you're an immigration attorney
you understand how dysfunction of this
process is would you acknowledge this is
a big win for the White House and the
American people it is smoke and mirrors
people we're not even talking
immigration reform guys not only are we
now admitting that we can't get the wall
built we're now admitted yeah they're
not gonna now Mexico's not gonna pay for
the wall in more worse we're gonna pay
for these development of jobs in Mexico
so not only are we admitting New
Mexico's not gonna pay for the wall
we're gonna give them money to employ
these Central Americans so they don't
come here and we're not even talking
about that
we're doing we're hoping them any money
we all realize can be read between the
lines because they don't work I'm
reading the line reading the lines right
here Francisco Princesa the lines right
here are that Mexico will offer jobs to
to folks who have been in these migrant
caravans there then we're not we're not
paying for the deployment of their
national we're not paying for the
deployment of their National Guard's
we're not parent paying for asylum
seekers we have sent back to Mexico
ultimately this is cisco how can you not
acknowledge that francisco some people
are coming here from Mexico's because
Mexico can't provide jobs for its own
citizens and we're American oh there but
oh they can would you not acknowledge
that their own government and the
cartels are facilitating this and so if
we can get a crackdown on the way people
are smuggled and treated as they come
into this country that's a win for both
countries and for the humanitarian
crisis we have at our border
I mean how why can't you acknowledge
register why can't you acknowledge these
are good steps in the right direction
what happened it there is no step we're
gonna end up paying for it and so at
least as long as you guys agree that
we're not gonna build a wall is that
what you guys bring no I don't think
we're agreeing on that's not talking
about that that's a 7:30 we're talking
about what's happening right now in the
next one you can take that up with the
courts who are disrupting this
president's plan to attempt to build
portions of that wall no doubt about it
but that it's a non sequitur to tonight
and I guess you're trying to distract
away from a clear victory when these
tariffs were criticized by many will
they hurt our economy is the right tool
but just a political victory it is a
human rights victory because children
are being smuggled and abused girls are
being raped this is an invitation from a
human rights perspective we got to do
something about it we can't wait for
Democrats and even even fake Republicans
who aren't willing to protect our
country
let's just go minutes to get when you
talk about policy how are you not
pointing at Congress how are you not
pointing at Congress or I am pointing
out of Congress absolutely they failed
to do their job absolutely which caused
us to come up with these crazy ideas
that terrorists were gonna stop people
from coming over while Mexico's gonna
provide Ceptor Americans brought an
opportunity where we've gotten new
concessions from Mexico and we're gonna
review them in 90 days how is that not a
win Mexico wasn't going to pay
tariffs you and I were are all because
they show us the targeting tool say
Mexico's pay for the internal security
of its National Guard Mexico is phasing
dapping to house and provide jobs for
those refugees read the report the
agreement it's very clear did I well you
haven't even read the ger cuz it just
happened in last hour but if you're
reading the lines I can read you say I
know that it says we're not paying for
jobs for Mexicans or for migrants in
Mexico that's what it does jobs goes
paying for it Mexican we get our
sovereignty which is the point of this
entire exercise let's come back tomorrow
and you show me where it says the
Mexican ninety days we will be waiting
it in 90 days maybe you can come join us
on five different song writing well
we've got to leave it right there it's a
debate ongoing but it's it's tough when
you're trying to debate something and
ultimately there is a women we can't be
knowledge Smoak and Meers there we go
our meeting Francisco thank you very
much for your time and different
perspectives